hi there I'm Miguel Concepcion with
gamespot and i'm here today with
Christian Alva damn from IO Interactive
to talk about the new Hokkaido map which
is the final chapter of the first season
of hitman Christian why don't you tell
me about what we get to experience in
this new map yeah so as you mentioned
we're going to Hokkaido Japan it's a
it's the very final mission in the in
the first season we are going to a very
remote facility very advanced facility
in in ho chi de which is a province that
is very very the nature there is pretty
well but the resort itself is the
shelter almost is very on the face of it
very luxurious location for only very
select sort of patients you don't really
get there unless the the Providence
group no shoe as we talked about also in
the in the plot and in the briefing for
the mission so 47 has enlisted himself
as a patient into this hospital and he
will start as such undercover and he has
to infiltrate the facility to eliminate
two different targets inside both the
hospital and also in the spa and sort of
a residential area for the patients one
thing I've really loved about this
episodic hitman game is every map has
its own flavor this map strikes me as a
mix of the resort from Bangkok because
as is a very welcoming exterior and also
the lab of the Italy map I don't know if
you can talk more about how you came
design no I I definitely see where
you're coming from I think under on the
surface it feels friendly a little bit
like tile and wood Italian was a in a
real sort of result if you will in this
case I think it's what's going on in the
facility itself is illegal and some of
the treatments they're doing are
absolutely not approved also involve
some organ harvesting and sort of more
sort of dark sort of takes you more dark
places so I think it it if the feeling
we wanted to go for with al-qaeda was
more that the it feels more restrictive
in the beginning
almost like even though it's super
beautiful you have a very nice Vista
when you sort of arrived it could almost
feel a little bit like a prison because
as a as a as a patient there you're also
it's sort of sort of throwing a
curveball that the players you obviously
starting without any gear at all you
just admitted to the hospital right so
you are allowed in a few places there's
a restaurant and a spy area and stuff
like that but but then it's actually you
have to make your way you almost have to
break out of your you're sort of patient
role if you will so and so I so it has
some similarities but it's definitely
also somewhat different again we also
just from looking at people how they've
been playing the game throughout the
season both with Colorado and al-qaeda
we wanted to sort of shake things up a
little bit so some of the rules that
you've grown accustomed to in Hokkaido I
changed a little bit if the facility is
run by a by an artificial intelligence
and that affects a lot of things like
disguise mechanics for instance well
well given the episodic structure of
this game you've in a way hook the
Hokkaido map was in a way formed by the
feedback and the initial reaction of the
of the Paris map of the ilume app can
you talk more about how that has evolved
absolutely I I am I think there are some
things that are obviously predetermined
so so we knew for a while we were going
to Japan and we're going to build a
hospital and the levels take some time
to do in the first place so so that
stuff we have to know but the difference
is then that the actual way that
Colorado or Hokkaido takes shape is
built with the confidence we got out of
building Paris and sapienza so if I look
back a little bit when we were building
parison sapienza and they came out sort
of for the first time we were really
curious and also somewhat nervous about
how would people perceive the the Hitman
sandbox it's been ten years or something
like we really did super complex maps
like that so the first period felt more
like watching people and is this going
to work what what what's going to happen
and I think we were fortunate in the
sense that by time of sapiens of people
said we really like hit man being back
to the sort of the classic formula which
meant that then when we looked at
Colorado Cairo became more self
confident in our ability to play a play
with the with the formula of the sandbox
so in that sense with ho chi de we
allowed ourselves to do things like
disguise mechanics that we would not
probably have done if we hadn't been
live for a while or if I mean it's a
hospital so I would say we play a little
bit around with one of the targets being
in the operating theatre and there are
some things I won't file too much around
how you assassinate that target that we
simply wouldn't have done necessarily in
the same way it had we not done the
other levels first well considering this
is the concluding chapter and that we
know that a second season is on the way
narrative Lee this tees up the second
season without spoiling anything and the
fact that a lot of players I think at
this point already know that there's
this organization called Providence how
would you how would you describe how
this tees up the second season well I
think so what it means for the first
season is that that in in the case of
oak idol we're obviously closing the
book on on one of the the characters
from the prologue Eric sodas and and in
this sense it's it's we call the mission
situs inversus which is obviously the
reverse condition basically but it's
also a nod to the to the prologue where
Eric sodas is the complete he's in
complete control of 47s fate is he going
to join the agency is he going to be
illuminated basically and as we show in
Colorado Eric sodas has been a
Providence mole for some time and he's
now a target in the final episode and
he's about to undergo surgery so now
he's at the complete mercy of 1847 and
we have some some elements in the level
that also play around that but as is the
case with with with us with a story that
that's also meant to spend seasons we
also open up some potential doors for
the future to come with the final
episode in the final cinematic so
specifically for a for our next season I
mean we are still at I'll we're just
shutting down she's in one looking at it
I still think we have a period of
looking at season one and what worked i
think the mindset we're in right now
looking at the feedback we're getting is
I think very positive because i think we
are now able to look at stuff that
worked and discuss how we can make it
even better
and we are also continuing the elusive
targets for a while longer so we're also
playing around with that format and then
we'll get around to what the next season
will be like but we don't know yet well
Christian thank you so much very time
thank you for more news and updates on
hitman please check gamespot com